Sam we've gotta talk about the dance
that Jamie does yes this is available
[Applause]
[Music]
this is something that the fans was
really hoping they were gonna get to see
from the fiery cross god defense oh
they'll be happy talk to me about
rehearsing that performing it on set
Katrina what was it like seeing him
being so light on there speechless when
you speak Irene I don't think I've
laughed so he took it very seriously I
mean there was a lot of rehearsing going
on he's very light on his feet it's it's
it's the Highland Fling it's actually
not a saw dance however they did put
salt in it but it was all about you know
the Highlanders kicking off the shackles
of the British so it's actually a dance
of defiance but it's this certainly nice
moment and the Scots are the really
really odd way of showing defiance
exactly the translates it's the compass
way possible it's actually it was
supposed to show your manliness because
you know they do it in the battlefield
you do in front of them and they'll see
this is the the state's thanks for the
snacks once which has been I think
assimilated to buy into will you me jest
but now see you do let us now tell you
great to be honest I have to say of
anyone standing in front of groups of
people having to do the whole thing fine
okay I'll do that but Katrina buff I was
terrified I was just waiting for it
you were very supportive very impressed
you were very supportive for you I see I
felt I felt the love
[Applause]
[Music]